hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
Greg and I am an eater I had got a lot
of requests to shoot this raw McDonald
versus KFC sign this was film live
apparently I go activated on my phone
the first person requested it but my
phone's dead huh
and I don't want to wait around for it
to boot up nobody wants to wait around
for that I just want to watch this we
just want to watch this [ __ ] boom
straight to the point straight to the
point point recorded live yeah you can
rule
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
they really vandalize a billboard oh
[Music]
[ __ ] already getting so much shovel
every court this is like evidence
against the actual
oh my goodness oh they're gonna get in
so much trouble
[Music]
[Music]
whatever get this reward no way it's
gotta be like the kind of sentence
hombre in the ground man Oh goddamn
[Music]
oh they have to twist one champion real
easy but there's life it's [ __ ] it's not
like they just feelers hanging oh my god
okay first of all there's no way to sign
with fake they had lights on it it was
like in the ground I mean it did come
apart pretty easily but there's no way
they're probably god damn take the fine
yeah it says lobster pending in the
description oh my god
dreamed live 14 hours yeah that's insane
I can't believe that actually like if it
was real it has to be fake you think I
don't know I mean Leslie like 3006 money
a legit billboard in there yeah I mean
the good night everybody have the money
to do something like that now I bet ya
they could have actually like planted
the whole thing so it looked like there
was props there that were you know like
the poop prop and stuff that looked like
it was legit okay so I want to tell you
about the little clip that you miss yeah
yeah no yeah you don't catch it yeah
they said to erase my Gabby yeah okay
yeah so I noticed that right away I was
like what because like there's this
YouTube drama going on I know you don't
really particularly you're that into the
YouTube drama but I follow like 17
youtube channels that has to do it like
philip defranco and like all the other
ones I'm just going to name
a little Gabi is this girl from the
gabbie show and right gum I don't know
if you know right yes okay well Gabi and
rice gum were at a party recently to get
like a YouTube get-together party
recently and rice gum is roasted Gabi
like in his videos in the past oh and so
she challenged him to a rap battle at
the party and was like let's do it right
now was snapchatting the whole thing and
apparently allegedly rice gum hit her
and broke her phone oh yeah yeah so this
is all a legend so I don't know exactly
what really happened because the video
of that particular incident wasn't shown
but yeah that's that's the drama right
now so that whole parody where he was
like daddy even said the name gather
there like was like hitting her and like
well she was snapchatting those that was
that is what that was I like a good
spoon yeah I thought Clippers because
they're like integrating like the you to
the recent YouTube drama in the video I
love that yeah well if they get sued
this will just boom their channel Lisa
shout if this is not real I love it even
more because I think this could be a
next wave of like if it's no say it's
not real yeah I would think it's like a
good wave of next sketches we're
definitely you're like was this real
yeah yeah and in the fact that they're
putting in like the effort and the money
if it's fake if they're putting in that
effort that's awesome that means that
they're going to come out with like
really good well I mean they already do
really good skits and [ __ ] but they're
gonna just they're going to up their
game a little bit so hoping for my to be
entertained sake that that is completely
real I hope that is so really gonna be
awesome and I guess line I don't know if
there's going to be a follow up to this
though I have no idea
are we gonna ever know will we ever know
will we ever find out yak is there a lot
of their video before this they were
joking about how their views have gone
down maybe that algorithm and the
restriction has affected them to that
age gate they're doing you
now you too look what sir look what
you're forcing youtubers to do what what
you're forcing under do know that what
you want is that what you want from us
is that advertiser friendly John stop
texting I'd an injustice [ __ ] hate
that guy IDs alright well thanks for
being here Anita thanks grant thanks for
all you guys and told me about this
rageh raka raka raka you're [ __ ]
amazing me I want to be in a sketch
thank you I'm good with all the
craziness just contact I mean the poop
can't be faked it can't be real no
definitely a probably yeah
I mean unless you know they're getting
crazy with it yeah you know I respect
them for it it's the direction they're
thinking it well I think they earned a
subscribers to go subscribe to them as
soon as possible
hey no wild subscribe to the real
rejects subscribe to the real rejects
stargazer on the Anita stargazer Channel
and and if you like boobs squeeze
[Music]